you know this story didn't get a lot of
light um it was definitely a shocker for
us when we walked into this that uh
uh you know someone charged with
terrorism uh
someone who that the federal government
identified as being part of a group that
was the number one domestic terror
threat in the nation uh could then not
be something that we all know about and
that was you know one of the many
entrees into the film
so essentially they got caught up in the
post-9 11
terrorism laws and and uh right i mean
that's the
and uh sort of though i mean the the
actually the the the terrorism charges
that were brought were pre-911 they were
pre-911 yeah timothy mcveigh era okay
and then when did you actually make this
film well it was post 9 11. so the the
the particular statute was written as
that that they used against him was
written as a result of of timothy
mcveigh
okay
but
i mean definitely the language of
post-9 11 america
and the sort of heat around the concept
of terrorism was part of uh
was part of the reason that they faced
life prison for these arsons right right
and the use of police informants and the
deals that are cut in order to get
people to testify against other people
and
and
those who
may have committed
more of a crime
than daniel um
didn't have to go didn't have to suffer
we didn't sir because he decided to
actually go through um yeah so he
the the
um
the guy who who started the earth
liberation from the united states was
the first you know took part in the
first action first arson um
and and
took part in dozens of arsons actually
um ultimately flipped and and uh wore a
wire the government flew him around the
country to get him together with all of
his old friends who had all since put
the earth liberation front behind them
and
and got them to talk about the old days
on tape and so in exchange for his
cooperation
he he
didn't have to go to prison at all um
although in the year
since the film came out he was um
arrested for selling drugs and is now in
prison so
so
good
um
well i i just again i thought this was
this was a really incredible film and um
and
and did what movies like this should do
it take us to a place we haven't been
expose us to something we knew nothing
about
um
and uh
um i found it riveting and uh thank you
for making it